quel est le prénom du montanier qui a
bien regardé dans son microscope pour
découvrir le virus responsable du sida à
la lâche commis le chanteur
non non je sèche à voir partir j'allais
pas le dire
et bah au hasard je veux dire bernard
c'est luc pas
et je vous ai dit je connaissais le
chanteur s'était oui m'enfin bon vous
êtes ambassadeur du sidaction depuis
juin 2020 mais vous êtes engagé depuis
très longtemps dans la lutte contre le
sida avec un slogan pour promouvoir l'
usage des préservatifs de toutes les
matières c'est le lurex que je préfère
c'est le latex latex
c'est ce qui est brillant vous savez ces
petits fils brillant et toi tu es tu là
mais c'est pas grave du tout mais c'est
très bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
jean luc mélenchon d'être venu sur ce
plateau pour vous exprimer sur votre
programme merci à vous merci on continue
avec la politique le candidat de debout
la france nicolas dupont aignan était en
visite dans une école privée de
marseille il y a décliné son programme
en matière d'éducation il prône le
retour aux fondamentaux et
je regrette qu'on parle peu de
l'éducation la date d'anniversaire de
jean luc mélenchon c'est quand que c'est
je crois le 19 août a pas mal celle d'
emmanuel macron ne faisait pas longtemps
parce qu'en tant que quelques semaines à
attendre décembre moi j'ai perdu un peu
la notion du temps depuis deux ans dhr
faut pas m'en vouloir
mais ça coûte gagner est ce que vous
savez faire mais signe de jul
c'est marseille bébé
pardon mais bon
[Applaudissements]
on arrive à l'activité barges les et là
on découvre trois baignoire remplie de
glace moi franchement g lara sera mon
cerveau et les tout petits j'ai trop
peur qu'ils se congèle là il ya beaucoup
trop de buchens pas me baigner dans du
jus c'est pas ben quoi c'est la galère
voilà donc c'est bien beau d'être beau
mais un mauvais escient sait pas
cuisiner là bas il faut pas participer
au dîner presque parfait alors qu'après
sa mort est chance à monsieur roger - le
culte de la personnalité peut-être de la
france est soumise est opérationnel mais
plat préféré de l'adema de mâcon vous le
connaissez ou pas du tout et je sais
qu'ils mangent beaucoup de choses et
dimanche beaucoup de choses
sinon dimanche simple à manier mc
alger pas été jusque là effectivement
bon jeu autant je bossais ce débat
alors je dirais mais je peux me tromper
brie de nangis brie de melun et brie de
meaux
pardon
c'est pas dit gros mots vous ai rien
entendu et leur plein leur principal
défaut alors principal défaut à vos
candidats est ce que vous serez capable
d'en sortir un
nouveau réussite et un défaut au
président de la république candidat à
l'élection d'après moi je passerai après
vous avez ces moments on est là j'y vais
j'y vais pas je lance la pub je la lance
pas avec du coup j'ai demandé à laurent
de la lancée pour moi en régie parce que
je sais pas tu en dualité
linguistique
c'est votre anniversaire aujourd'hui oui
[Applaudissements]
et
ollier verbe avoir réfléchi
il a pas l'air de bien connaître
je connais bien monsieur mac os non mais
je connais bien sûr quand c'est
quelqu'un qui sait vous mettre la
pression un pas que j'avais vécu ça
m'est arrivé sur la campagne vaccinale
est souvent à raison donc j'en fais pas
un défaut plus sur une qualité surtout
quand on est présent la république